good afternoon my name is Bill Summers
and on behalf of the Yale University and
the my fellow members of the Terry
lectureship committee I welcome you to
this series of Terry lectures on Islam
science and the challenge of History to
be presented by Professor Ahmad Dalal
the Dwight H Terry lectureship was
established at Yale in 1905 by a gift
from Dwight Harrington Terry of
Bridgeport Connecticut the deed of gift
from Mr Terry declares that the object
of this Foundation is not the promotion
of scientific investigation discovery
but rather the assimilation to an
interpretation of what has been or shall
hear after be discovered and its
application to human welfare
especially by the building of the truths
of Science and philosophy into the
structure of a broadened and purified
religion the founder believes that such
a religion will greatly stimulate
intelligent effort for the Improvement
of human conditions and the advancement
of the race in strength and Excellence
of character
to this end it is desired that a series
of lectures be given by men eminent of
their respective departments on ethics
the history of civilization and religion
biblical research all sciences and
branches of knowledge which have been
important in on in bearing on the
subject and the great laws of nature
especially of evolution
well the electors have had an enduring
permanence through their publication and
book form by the Yale University press
and for more immediate engagement of the
material in this series there is an
interactive website that allows you both
to pose questions and have discussion as
well as to review the lecture which will
be available online the URL for that
website is
www.yale.edu backslash Terry lecture
right after the reception the talk there
will be a reception out in the hall
there where we can have informal
conversations and I welcome you all to
stay
Professor Dalal earned his bachelor's
degree in mechanical engineering from
the American University of Beirut and
worked as an engineer while developing
his knowledge of culture and Science
Under the tutelage of Professor Edward
Kennedy the renowned scholar of Arabic
astronomy and mathematics professor
Delaware received his PhD in Islamic
Studies from Columbia University and has
held faculty positions at Smith Yale
Stanford before taking his present
position at Georgetown University where
he is the chair of the Arabic and
Islamic Studies Department Professor
Jalal tells me that while at Yale he's
lectured in this Hall himself and so we
welcome him back to this this venue his
academic training and research covers
the history of the disciplines of
learning in the Muslim societies
including both the exact and traditional
Sciences as well as modern and early
modern Islamic thought and movements
um
Professor Dalal arrives in New Haven
from Morocco where he's engaged in a
year-long research project as a Carnegie
scholar his lectures in this series
which are foreign number uh on Tuesdays
and Thursdays of this week and next are
on the general topic Islam science and
the challenge of history and it's a real
pleasure to welcome back my colleague
and friend and our secretary lecture for
the year Ahmad Dalal thank you
good afternoon
thank you Bill
it's an honor to be here to be invited
to give the 30 lectures and I would like
to thank the the relationship committee
for giving me this honor it's also a
great pleasure to be back with
colleagues I spent six years at Yale and
there were great years and I learned so
much and it's always a pleasure to be
back
Muslims are enjoying to face Mecca
during their five daily prayers
and all masks are supposed to be
oriented towards the Kaaba in Mecca the
cubicle structure in Makkah or what is
known as the direction of the Qibla
before mathematical methods became
available to them
Muslims determined the direction of the
Qibla based on the practices of the
early Companions of the prophet
and their successives they also made use
of traditions of folk astronomy
and of the fact that the Kaaba itself is
astronomically oriented
these methods provide a reasonable
approximations in locations close to
Mecca such as
and Syria and Iraq but were quite
inaccurate in Far Away places like North
Africa and Iran
with the emergence of mathematical
Sciences new mathematical methods of
considerable sophistication were devised
to compute the Qibla for any locality on
the basis of the geometric geographical
coordinates of the totality end of
Makkah
and the most accurate solution the
problem is transferred to the celestial
sphere where the position of the Zenith
of Mecca relative to the Zenith of the
locality is determined the direction of
the Qibla is then calculated as the
Azimuth of the Zenith of Mecca on the
local Horizon
most astronomical handbooks contain
chapters in finding the direction of the
Qibla by one or more approximately of or
accurate method
and separate treatises were also
composed on the subject
in his many works on astronomy in the
surface of Islam David King has noted
that although jurists and scientists
often proposed very different solutions
to the same problem
Juris criticized mathematical astronomy
only when it was used in astrology
and did not criticize exact mathematical
methods that differed from their own
methods
scientists on the other hand rarely
spoke against the simplified methods of
the religious Scholars put differently
alternative methods of radically
different provenance one relying on
religious tradition and the other on
mathematical astronomy were tolerated
the direction of the Qibla however was
one major exception to this general rule
as I said beyond the hijaz Syria and
Iraq many of the mosques which were
built in the early period of Islamic
expansion were misaligned
with increased knowledge of mathematical
astronomy however this flow was
recognized
and while some of the misaligned mosques
retained their orientation others were
rebuilt to face the correct direction of
Mecca
this presented a serious problem
namely the problem of having to tear
down mosques which were built on the
authority of the companions of the
prophet
and doing that because of the authority
of mathematical astronomers
more generally the question raised was
whether mathematical knowledge should
take precedence over religious Authority
in a matter where admittedly the realm
of the Realms of Science and religion
overlapped
I will start my lectures with a very
brief overview of a debate that spanned
several centuries roughly from the 12th
in the manuscripts at least and books
that I examined roughly from the 12th
till the early 18th century on the
problem of the direction of the Qibla of
fast first is
one of the oldest cities in Morocco
I do not intend in this brief outline to
treat the problem in any detail
not to address the general question of
the relationship between science and
religion which is the subject of my
third lecture rather I would like to use
the all the use the the overview of the
problem of the Qibla Affairs as a way of
introducing the problematics that I
would like to address in the in in my
lectures
according to the participants in the
debate and over over the direction of
the Qibla of first a number of
difficulties associated with finding the
Qibla in North Africa
uh were identified not least because the
religious Scholars who offered the
authoritative legal Works used in North
Africa did not mention ways of finding
the direction of a Qibla using the stars
and the rising and setting of the Sun
a second difficulty according to these
sources arise from the fact that there
are drastic differences in the
orientation of different mosques it was
in in their face as it were
such that one finds in the same city
some mosques which are directed to the
East and others to the South
those who direct their Moses to the
South rely on the Hadith of the Prophet
which says quote between the East and
the West is a Qibla
and take this to be a general Hadith
While most religious Scholars and
certainly most astronomers consider this
Hadith to be relevant only to Medina to
the city of the prophet and to similar
regions such as Syria
one important work on the subject on
this particular subject was written by a
person by the name of tajuri a 16th
century religious scholar and time
keeper
book includes a question soliciting the
fatwas or religious rulings or opinions
of Scholars of Cairo and and Egypt in
general about the mosques of fast which
were directed towards the South
including the city's famous
mosque the most important mosque School
complex in Morocco
tajuri maintains that these mosques are
not directed towards what he calls the
legal Qibla the Sharia
which is the Eastward direction of Mecca
in addition to the wrong interpretation
of the Hadith I just mentioned those who
defend the false Qibla invoke the
precedent or the practice of the early
generations of Muslims who built the
first mosques in in Morocco in the
presence and with the consent of
religious Scholars
to be sure these early mosques were
built before the rise of the rise of a
scientific culture in the Muslim world
but the religious authority of their
Builders was upheld even after the rise
of science
given the gravity of this of of this
challenge
it's not surprising that tajuri the
author of this particular book wished to
master as much religious support for his
position and that's why he solicited the
fatwas of religious scholars in in Egypt
in addition to the support of the
scholars of Egypt Egypt tajuri also used
the religious language to refer to the
Qibla calling it The Qibla of the
Companions and and some such
terms yet despite his veneer of
religiosity the real question was
whether the qiblaw was to be determined
on the basis of religious precedence or
mathematical astronomy
the jury was criticized and defended by
several fascist Scholars who were
concerned in this particular case the
most concerned in this particular case
but for the purposes of this very brief
introduction the most interesting
defense of tajuri's views was by late
17th century discolored by the name of
Phil Arabi even Abdullah
al-face refers to a distinction some
people make between the jiha of the
Qibla which means the general direction
of the Qibla and Descent of the Qibla
which means the precise Azimuth of the
Zenith of Mecca the mathematical of the
Zenith of Mecca
who make this distinction suggest that
the only requirement of the law is that
Muslims face the general direction of
the Qibla without requiring knowledge of
its exact mathematical coordinates
which will would involve of course
knowledge of the science of geometry
and since knowledge of geometry is not a
legal obligation then no other legal
obligation could be contingent on it
in response to this rather compromising
View
first it insists that the meaning of of
jiha of the general direction answered
the exact mathematical direction are the
same
and that geometry is not different from
any other commonly used skill in his
word craft such as construction and
commerce
because and I'm quoting tajur here each
craft which involves precision and
measurement partakes in geometry
fussy distinguishes between two senses
of the term jihar Direction
as an object as an objective in itself
or as a means for finding the direction
the ultimate objective he adds is to
find the mathematical coordinates of the
direction of the Kaaba whereas the
second sense of the term refers to
approximate approximations similar to
the one indicated in the Hadith of the
prophet
furthermore the exercise according to
tajuri the exercise of independent legal
is in English
and matters related to the Qibla is only
valid through the use of proofs which
are suitable for finding this direction
and not through gas and conjecture
and of course from from tajuri Festival
refers to a legal opinion attributed to
Iman Malik whose Doctrine is the
official legal School of North Africa
of Malik Malik
argues that if the orientation of a
mosque is based on Independent legal
reasoning honest Jihad then an error
does not require rebuilding it in
response first it maintains that this
would be true if the HD head is based on
proofs derived from astronomy or from
the use of astronomical tables or the
like and that there is no Credence in
any shihad which is not based on such
mathematical proofs
after noting the argument that holding
all Muslims responsible on the basis of
mathematical knowledge which only a few
can maintain is contrary to the spirit
of Islamic law
after noting this argument fastly
retorts that each and I'm quoting here
each craft has its Masters and nothing
comes easy
learning how to find the direction of
the Qibla is similar to The Learning
other Sciences in fact it might even be
easier than learning more elaborate
texts and it's attainable in a short
period
in large cities fasi argues it's illegal
for someone who does not know how to
find the direction of the Qibla to build
a mosque unless he is accompanied by the
masters of The Craft who know the proofs
of the qiblical he calls it it is only
permissible to erect The Mask which is
oriented towards the direction of Mecca
and someone who does not know the proof
of the Qibla should not exercise his if
she had even if he happens to be a
jurist
because the most a jurist can know and
I'm quoting fussy here the most a jurist
can know and his capacity as a jurist is
that it's obligatory to face the Qibla
and that is obligatory foreign
in other words to imitate a mathematical
astronomer
that is to imitate one who knows the
suitable proofs for it
fussy adds that the real mustaches in
the matter of the Qibla
using proofs suitable for it are
astronomers and not tourists because the
prerequisite of this ishtihad is
knowledge derived from The Sciences of
mathematics astronomy time keeping the
position of the planets and the
computation of directions and all of
these are outside the domain of the
legal Sciences
furthermore the ishtihad of astronomers
in the matter of the Qibla is not
similar to the istihad of tourists in
applied law
because there is only one correct
outcome for this in the case of the
Qibla whereas for Judas is
exercises his best who does his best is
correct in applied law this is why in
the matter of the Qibla the astronomers
are given precedence over tourists
because each craft again has its Masters
and the Masters of The Craft of funding
Qibla are the astronomers
if the biological questions raised in
these texts reflect widespread
discussions that took place in many
fields and over a very long period of
time
owing to the Practical nature of the
Qibla debate the conceptual categories
under discussion May at times seem vague
but these issues were articulated with
much more precision and other
theoretical debates
the significance of the Qibla debate is
that precise epistemological discussions
filtered down to the most sensitive
matter of Prayer and raised in no
uncertain terms the question of
intellectual Authority within as it were
the most Sacred Space in Islam
quite clearly this was not an academic
debate relegated to the margins of
Islamic culture mosques were actually
told down and rebirth
by the debate which is constitutive of
this culture and as I will I will argue
is one of its characteristic features
in the following lectures I will examine
the cultural significance of scientific
knowledge and will try to situate the
culture of Science in relation to other
cultural forces in Muslim societies
the primary question for the lectures is
what cultural forces provided the
conditions of possibility of such
epistemological debates
what was the content context in which
these debates emerge and were sustained
I will base my analysis on texts
determining the significance of
scientific texts and by by extension of
scientific knowledge is contingent on
situating these texts within the tripart
Nexus of three systems of knowledge
religion philosophy and science
any understanding of the cultural
significance of Islamic scientific
thought requires by necessity I think an
evaluation of the relationship between
science and philosophy on one hand and
science on and religion on the other
I will address
these relationships in the second and
third lectures
and in the last lecture I will describe
what I think is a radical departure in
modern times from the model that was
carefully negotiated and The Classical
period of Islam
before I proceed with this examination
what I would like to do today is to try
to identify again very very briefly
what I think are some of the
characteristic features of the arable
Islamic scientific culture and in the
process perhaps highlights some key
questions in the historiography of
Science in Muslim societies
beginnings
the history of Arab Islamic Sciences is
part of a larger non-linear history that
relates to earlier scientific traditions
and that exerted scientific influences
on later traditions
however the arable Islamic Sciences are
not reducible to what came before
nor is their significance simply on
account of what happened after
the genealogical and teleological
approaches to the history of Islamic
science are legitimate subjects of
inquiry know that but they are not the
primary concern of my Approach in in the
four lectures that I will deliver rather
I'm more interested in examining the
Islamic scientific culture as a
historical occurrence whose Singularity
derives from The Peculiar ways it
relates to other cultural forces within
Muslim Society
to be sure a historical account of the
Islamic Sciences may choose to ignore
the fate of this scientific tradition
and to focus on its life within its own
historical context without losing much
of a historical value but no account of
this tradition can hold without
addressing the question of Beginnings
that is the conditions that under which
an arable Islamic scientific culture
emerged
however determining the beginning or
Beginnings probably is is more accurate
is itself partly a function of the
epistemological assumptions of the
historian
before the coming of Islam and for the
for over a century after its rise Arabs
had no science
without exception historians of Islamic
science have rightly identified the
translation movement the bulk of which
took place in the course of the 9th
century as the most important factor in
the emergence of an Islamic scientific
culture
this translation movement of works from
Indian sources from Persian sources but
primarily from Greek this translation
movement provided the knowledge base of
the emerging Sciences
but while this explains part of the
picture and admittedly one
of its most important parts it does not
provide a full explanation of the
beginnings
to start with
what are the socio-political conditions
and the cultural attitudes that
triggered interest in Translation and
Science in the first place
second what were the cultural conditions
that enabled the significant community
of interest to know how to translate
complex scientific texts to develop a
technical the technical terminology
needed for the transfer of scientific
knowledge between two languages
to understand scientific texts once they
are translated and to constructively
engage the knowledge derived from them
seen in this slide translation is not a
mechanical process but as part of a
complex historical process which is not
reducible to the transfer of external
knowledge rather it involves forces
intrinsic to the receiving culture
and finally the lies of Science of the
Sciences enabled by the translations are
related to but not identical with the
life of the translation movement itself
the moment of translation important as
it is is only an aspect
of and one factor in the subsequent
development of the arable Islamic
Sciences hence the title of this lecture
beginnings and Beyond
the historical significance of
scientific ideas and practices is shaped
by multiple historical factors
that an account of Origins cannot
possibly exhaust
in addition to Origins it's important to
ask if and how individual scientific
ideas acquired specific meanings in
their new Islamic cultural context what
departures and Innovations were
occasioned by giving these ideas a new
home
the focus here is not on precedent
despite the importance of the subject in
the field of History of Science
rather my focus on is on the way ideas
were received in their own cultural
context how they enabled new practices
and affected further developments in
their own and other disciplines and on
the kinds of thinking and practices that
were engendered by this cumulative
process
of course in the remaining time I will
have to make you know very broad
generalizations uh
on a subject which is vast the the scale
of scientific production and Muslim
societies is is massive over about eight
centuries there are thousands of of
scientists who were engaged in in
multiple scientific activities all over
the Muslim World there are tens if not
hundreds of thousands of of scientific
words that were produced new disciplines
many many new disciplines were invented
and so on and so forth I think however
it's possible to to attempt a
generalization
although the vast majority of scientific
manuscripts remain unstudied and in some
cases even not even catalog but it's
possible given the amount of of studies
that were produced in the last three
decades or so it's possible to to attend
a generalization of the kind that I'm
attempting today but I should say up
front that this is a generalization and
you know I look forward to to your
comments to to refine the argument uh
later on
for today's purposes
for the purposes of this lecture The
Works that I will draw on most are two
interpretive essays written in the last
decade which have attempted to address
in systematic ways the social and
historical roots of the translation
movement in particular and the social
factors that contributed to the rise and
development of scientific thought in
general and allow me to to elaborate a
little bit because these two studies are
are quite important regarding today's
subject
these are two books published both
published in 1998 by Professor Dimitri
gutas who's here and and Professor
George Saliba my own advisor the first
is Arabic thought as Greek thought
Arabic culture and the the saliva's book
is
Arabic scientific thought Origins and
development
significant differences between these
two studies and these two Scholars one
main difference is that Saliba situates
the main impetus for the rise of the
Arab Islamic science and the arabization
of the administrative apparatus during
the mid-8th century
that is during the reign of of the
umayyad caliph if you're familiar with
the caliphs and and with the political
history of Islam
Abdul Malik whereas gutas argues that
this impetus derived mainly from the
Imperial ideology adopted by the Elia
Abbasid caliphs especially uh one
particular
and which provided material support and
hence created an atmosphere conducive to
the development of science
this material support according to
Saliba catered to social needs but
derived mainly from the decision of the
umayyad ruler to dedicate huge resources
for restructuring the state apparatus
another significant difference is that
gutas identifies and identifies interest
in political astrology as an aspect of
the ideological Outlook of the abbasids
whereas Saliba argues that astrology
played a role in the development but not
rise of science
this is aside to my mind
has made disagree with me later I think
these two interpretations share a common
approach to the question of beginnings
and the primary problematics address
them both studies are quite similar
as are the types of questions they ask
and these are the points I would like to
draw to to underscore in in my lecture
today above all both Scholars treat the
translation movement and the scientific
activity more broadly as a complex
phenomena that does not lend itself to a
single track and to single track and
static explanations scientific
activities included including
translation received white support from
various classes and thus cannot be
explained as traditional accounts often
suggested in terms of the of the
interests of any particular group or the
whims and proclivities of any particular
ruler most studies make a compelling
case for situating the translation
movement in the context of an emerging
emerging scientific tradition and the
growing Muslim Urban centers that
culminated in Baghdad as such
translation is seen as an aspect of this
emerging scientific culture and not its
mechanical cause
and what's perhaps their main
contribution to my mind at least these
two studies recognize a major Gap in
earlier scholarship on Islamic science
namely the failure of the scholarship to
identify a living scientific tradition
within the Islamic cultural space that
would explain the seemingly sudden
appearance of a thriving scientific
culture in the early Decades of the 9th
century
for translations to be understood and to
have an impact there must have existed a
scientific culture what I would call
Knowledge base
on which further knowledge could be
grafted
saliva argues that during the period of
the arabization of the administrative
apparatus a group of people became
qualified and acquired foundational
knowledge of the basics of various
Sciences ghoutas on the other hand
argues the existence in the 7th and 8th
centuries of what he calls international
Scholars these were multilingual
Scholars who knew Greek Arabic Syria
pallavi these were multilingual
scientifically competent Scholars
working in a region unified under
Islamic Rule and representative of a
living scientific tradition before the
period of translation
this International Scholars practice
their profession in whatever environment
offered the best support thereby
transmitting much scientific knowledge
without translation and when the
ambassad Imperial ideology gave rise to
a need
and provided support for increased
scientific activities a critical mass of
Specialists came from the ranks of these
International Scholars
whether it's through these International
Scholars all the skilled professionals
involved in the arabization of the
umayyad administrative apparatus by the
beginning of the 9th century scientific
activity in the Muslim on the Muslim
world was was ready to make a
quantitative leap towards a more
systematic and homogeneous scientific
and philosophical Enterprise
at this point in time the Practical
social and political needs coupled with
theoretical and scholarly needs and this
is I would like to underscore this is
the second Point scholarly needs
scientific needs gave rise to and and
nurtured the systematic translation
movement that had a great impact on the
subsequent development of scientific
culture in the Muslim world
the two works I quoted
here clearly Illustrated that in
addition to social and political factors
the conditions for the rise of a
scientific culture must include an
account of the knowledge base that made
interest in the sciences and the
subsequent scientific activities
possible
to the list of factors contributing to
the formation of this this prerequisite
knowledge knowledge base we should also
mention the linguistic activities of
early Muslim Society
preceding 9th century translations
the earliest scholarly Productions among
Muslims were of a linguistic nature
of particular relevance to the letter
development of science was the extensive
compilation efforts by Arabic
philologists and lexicographers the
specialized lexicons that were produced
in this period represent a large-scale
attempt at collecting and classifying
the knowledge of the Arabs quote unquote
these attempts were not always
scientific and they were eclipsed
certainly by later more systematic
achievements nonetheless these
encyclopedic efforts provided the
linguistic Foundation which fostered the
development of the various intellectual
disciplines the foundational
philological work done by the early
lexicographers was the first step at
organizing knowledge and in the
production of a scientific culture
in addition to this and foundational
linguistic efforts in certain cases
momentum for scientific research derived
derived from interest in language
Sciences
combinatorial analysis for example was
one such field it developed not just in
connection with algebraic research but
also linguistics
to compile an exhaustive Arabic lexicon
who died in 786 in the 8th Century
before the the beginning of the main
sort of translation movement started
and one of the earliest other
lexicographers
enumerated for all the letters of the
Arabic alphabet all the possible
combinations of words with roots Arabic
systematic language as you know and it's
it all words have a root of three to
five letters so he enumerated all the
possible combinations of words with
roots of three to five letters
first restructured the words of the
Lexicon on formal grounds
thereby exhausting the domain of what he
called the possible language
defining real language as called the
vocally actualized part of the possible
language Al Khalil then proceeded to
eliminate those words that are not
empirically verifiable in actual usage
by providing a theoretical solution to a
practical linguistic problem
rationalized empirical practice of
lexicography more importantly this
linguistic activity provided an
incentive for research in the in the
field of competitorial analysis
now one of the most commonly repeated
assertions and general histories of
science is that the rational sciences
and Islam were marginalized because of
the lack of institutions of
institutional support
the primary evidence for this
marginalization thesis is educed from
the alleged exclusion of the rational
Sciences from the curricula of formal
institutions of learning
in his classic work on the rise of
colleges George magdesi contends that
the quintessential institutions of
learning in Muslim societies the madrasa
and it's antecedent and cognitive
institutions were exclusively devoted to
the study of the legal sciences and
other ancillary religious and
philological disciplines and had no room
for the rational Sciences there is a
long debate that I will have to skip in
the interest of time but one significant
reason relatively recent significant
exception to the relevant relative
consensus among Scholars of Islamic
education on the marginality of the
Sciences in the in the is the
contribution of scholar by the name of
Sonia brentis
brentis surveys the social and cultural
spaces for the practice of the rational
science and Muslim societies using
accounts in biographical dictionaries
she argues that like the religious
Sciences education in in the exact
Sciences was a stable aspect of
Education in Muslim societies
furthermore this education took place
within recognizable networks whose
structures parallel those of the
religious Sciences
this observation is born by the
information cult from the biographical
dictionaries and from the Abundant use
in these sources of parallel discourses
to describe describe education in the
rational as well as traditional Sciences
in these discourses on education and
knowledge the rational Sciences are
always presented and treated with
respect and are often presented in
Alliance with the religious Sciences
in fact the evidence for the presence of
of the rational Sciences as a
constitutive element in the educational
landscape of classical Muslim Societies
in my view is simply overwhelming above
all the testimony for this constant
presence comes from the actual
combination of religious and scientific
scholarship in the persons of numerous
Scholars especially after the 12th
century in different regions and periods
countless colors produced Advanced
scholarship in such Fields as Hadith the
traditions of the Prophet Muhammad and
Madison quranic exegesis and astronomy
law and philosophy not to mention
theology grammar logic and many more
scholar often alternated teaching
religious and scientific disciplines in
in the same places moreover the rational
Sciences were always present in the many
classifications of science that
proliferated an Islamic scholarship
further evidence for the respectability
of the rational Sciences is the Abundant
side-by-side appearance in biographical
dictionaries of Scholars of the rational
and religious Sciences moreover in
countless entries
in biographical dictionaries which are
dedicated to such disciplines as Islamic
law the study of Hadith or other
religious disciplines the command by
individual Scholars of the rational
Sciences is celebrated as a positive
trait without any qualification
a significant number of entries also
mentioned that these their subjects
studied or taught one or more of the
secular sciences and wrote books in
these fields
significantly similar expressions and
terms are used to praise a Scholar's
knowledge in rationale as well as
religious Sciences
the example cited so far are from
biographical dictionaries dedicated to
religious scholarship
equally important is the emergence of a
specialized kind of biographical
dictionaries dedicated to Physicians
or practitioners of the rational
Sciences
as with other kinds of biographical
dictionaries these specialized
biographies reflect the communities
awareness first of all of its own
professional and intellectual identity
moreover these Works serve as attempts
by a community to legitimize its own
knowledge and to present it as a wealthy
achievement of the larger Muslim
Community
thereby situating a particular
professional practice within the
mainstream of Islamic culture
through these and other means the
pursuit of science was conceptualized as
an act that has social and
epistemological value in its own right
in addition to these modes of
sanctioning science other structures
were instituted to promote instituted to
promote and support scientific activity
as as I already noted science was taught
in a variety of venues ranging from
private homes to endowed and structured
settings
similarly science was practiced in
various locales ranging from private
homes again to formal Institution
medicine for example
was taught privately in the homes of
individual Physicians but it was also
taught systematically in endowed
hospitals and as of the 12th or 13th
centuries it was also taught in endowed
schools that were established
exclusively for the teaching of of
medicine
I could go on and on about medicine and
the institutions for teaching medicine
the teaching of mathematics and
astronomy also
was was partly integrated into the
curricula of religious schools through
the discipline of al-faraded which means
inheritance algebra inheritance laws are
a bit complex in in Islam and solving
you know an inheritance problems could
be a challenge and you really need to
know algebra second degree equations at
least and there is a discipline which
was developed it was called which is
inheritance algebra and that was taught
in Many religious settings another
discipline time keeping the sense of
time keeping mikhat which tells with
with the timekeeping and calendar
computation visibility of moon and so on
was also taught in in religious settings
and we have while we have some evidence
for the teaching of theoretical
astronomy after the 13th century in
religious schools
we are much more informed about the
institutional framework for the practice
of the science of astronomy
one such institution was the observatory
and I will skip this part there were a
number of observators throughout of
course the thing about observatories is
that you know they're not the main
institutions for for the practice or
teaching of of science but they endowed
the practice with Prestige and we you
know that's one way of getting money and
and so on and so forth
but Islamic history is punctuated with a
number of significant of very important
observatories starting with the
beginning again of the translation
movement in the beginning in the in the
in the beginning of the of the in the
first quarter of the of the ninth
Century uh established sort of uh
assembled a group to do observations
first in Baghdad and then when these
observations didn't work he sent them to
Syria to do to conduct another set of
observation and compare them and so on
and so forth and that practice continued
throughout there are there are a series
of of observatories that were formed
some of the most important work in
theoretical astronomy was actually
produced by people who work with such
Observer there is one particular
Observatory 13th century lasted for
about
very active for about 30 years and
continued for for more than half a
century and some of the most important
people were working in theoretical
astronomy was produced in it so this is
one one set of institutions
although not all of uh and the thing
about about this institution is is that
um
there are institutional features that
are very either visible in in in these
observatories
now a different model for the social
sanctioning of astronomy and the related
integration of astronomical institutions
within Society is the emergence of of
the office as I said of the time keeper
and many mosques all over the Muslim
World although time keeping activities
are not identical with the activities
conducted at observatories they did
provide stable facilities and resources
for use by individual astronomers
from a pure scientific point of view
there are cases when the achievements of
timekeepers were Superior to those of
Observatory astronomers if you if I may
use it then the best example of course
is the celebrated but he's not the only
one there are many many others aside
from her the best example is the
celebrated 14th century astrono the
machine astronomer of the shutter who
occupied the position of a timekeeper at
the amazing in Damascus
conducted extensive observations
designed and constructed new instruments
and produced the most advanced and
successful contributions of astronomical
Islamic astronomy in the field of
planetary Theory
so this is another setting and one could
go on and on on the subject now
the practice of science therefore did
not occur in a vacuum and while the
modes of supporting this practice
changed over time and varied with
discipline there can be no doubt that
right from the beginning The Sciences
were an enduring feature of the
intellectual landscape of Muslim
societies
Beginnings were also instrumental in
shaping the practice of science in ways
that had lasting effects on its later
development
in the course of the lectures I will
repeatedly remind you of the
predominance of the Greek scientific
tradition and of its vital influence on
the development of arable Islamic
Sciences however despite the Paramount
importance of the Greek Traditions
Arabic Sciences
did more than simply preserve the Greek
scientific Legacy and pass it to its
European Earth
in fact evidence from the earliest
extent scientific sources indicates that
the translation movement was concurrent
with rather than a prerequisite for
scientific research in the Islamic world
simultaneous research and translation
took place in more than one field and in
more than one case even when some of the
scientific texts were being translated
they were also reformulated and
transformed
and attempting to explain this phenomena
it's worth keeping in mind that the
absorption of the Greek Persian and
Indian scientific legacies into the
Islamic culture took place in the
context of a dominant Islamic polity
to put it differently Muslims were not
in a position of political subordination
which probably explains the ease with
which they were willing to borrow from
other cultures
to my mind I was more important than
this possible sense of security
is the multiplicity of the scientific
legacies that informed Islamic science
in a classic and much quoted work on the
history of Arabic astronomy published in
1911.
Carlo nalino downplays the Persian and
Indian influences and suggests that the
scientificity
if I may use this word of Arabic science
is largely due to its Reliance on the
Greek Sciences
however without denying the
disproportionate weight of the Greek
tradition I would argue that the other
two legacies were extremely important in
two respects
first because they explained some of the
earliest research in in fields such as
algebra uh which were concurrent with
and not subsequent to the beginnings of
the translation of the Greek
mathematical Works autonomic power and a
famous historian of Science and a
passing remark in his exact sciences and
Antiquity uh suggests that you know this
appearance of you know right at the
beginning of the translation movement
the appearance of a new science a
completely new science perhaps has
Babylonian or Origins but the second and
more important point which makes these
other Traditions the Greek the Indian
and and Persian Traditions important is
because of the availability of multiple
scientific Traditions to choose from the
available availability of multiple
Traditions to truths from a loud and
eclectic and discriminating approach to
each of the inherited scientific
Legacies
the early dynamics of translation and
original composition suggests that the
small amount of non-greek translations
had the effect of hybridizing knowledge
which in turn had the lasting impact on
the attitude towards the dominant Greek
Sciences again I don't have time to get
into this in great detail algebra as a
case in point but more important
probably than algebra algebra was was
it's a new science which was invented by
khawarismi of course there were people
who performed algebraic operations way
before before the rise of Islam and in
many earlier Traditions but algebra as a
science which has its new title which
has its subject matter which is
algebraic equations as opposed to Simply
performing an open an algebraic
operation without calling it a science
which has its own terminology and so on
and so forth it has its methods which is
systematic and meant to be exhaustive
all of this happened with the invention
of kitable after after which the the the
science is named again in the game of
the 9th century
now more important than algebra the the
the
already in the second half of the
century
one of the translators had translated
the first seven books of the arithmetica
of theophantes into Arabic significantly
however the Arabic translation was was
given the title The Art of algebra
uh
the translator's use of the language and
conception of the new field of algebra
reoriented the arithmetica of the
advantis and provided instead an
algebraic interpretation of this
arithmetic and which later people
recognized and they they re-translated
the arithmetics so that it's faithful to
the original but you could see how the
invention of a new tradition actually
transformed
a work of translation as it's being
translated
in this particular instance the
translation from Greek into Arabic was
both motivated and conditioned by the
earlier original research in Arabic
algebra
this illustrates the transformative
effects of the Cross application of
multiple scientific disciplines and how
old Sciences can be restructured and
used new science is constructed by
applying the tools of one discipline to
another and this became a favorite sort
of
motif throughout the the Islamic
Sciences take one science and apply it
one another and see what happens and
invariably there are new Sciences which
were invented this way the first in
mathematics first was the application of
of algebra on arithmetics then the
arithmetization of of algebra itself a
systematic attempt to arithmetize
algebra and and and and later on again
applied geometry to algebra and you know
geometric algebra was was was the
discipline of dramatic algebra was was
invented more than any other scholar
rishti Rashid has done tremendous work a
historian of Arabic mathematics has done
tremendous work to to outline these
these development
similar thing can be traced in astronomy
again multiple disciplines the earliest
works that were translated in astronomy
were Persian and and India and the
earliest extant work which was also
composed by resmi original work composed
by khawarismi has many Indian parameters
in it and also it uses parameters from
ptolema's handy tables and so on and so
forth so the earliest works that we have
in in
astronomy as well have similar features
a similar thing can be traced in
medicine
the first systematic comprehensive work
was composed by uh
in the mid 9th century and it's called
Paradise of wisdom
and again it's a combination of Indian
medicine and and Greek medicine it's
very eclectic and and so on and so forth
now the point that I'm trying to make I
can't I mean the examples are endless in
almost every single case one could see
a scientific discipline one can find
examples the point I'm I'm trying to
make is that the main role of Indian
medicine was not to adore science was
not to define the Contours of the Arabic
medical tradition or the Arabic
scientific tradition but to set the tone
for some of its initial interests and
Curiosities although the Greek
scientific Legacy was the dominant one a
mere awareness of more than one
available tradition encouraged a
critical and selective approach that
pervades all fields of Arabic science
a critical awareness of the possibility
of multiple interpretations and
approaches to various scientific
disciplines characterize the practice of
science throughout the 9th and century
and beyond this in turn resulted in
three related Trends first a thorough
mathematics examination of the details
of various disciplines to sort of
perfect the details of the disciplines
in astronomy for example examine all the
parameters and observations of Ptolemy
and see if you could refine them make
them better and so on
um
an attempt the second is an attempt to
systematize and generalize these
disciplines and finally the production
of exhaustive synthesis of individual
disciplines as well as several related
ones
uh again there are numerous cases that I
could uh that I could I hope some would
ask me questions about the subject I'd
be glad to come back to it I I have to
move on but we can trace this in in all
the fields in mathematics and and in
astronomy in medicine and in many others
and Optics and and so on
now the the second the the another point
that I would like to to highlight
is the invention of new Sciences one of
the distinctive results of the
reorganization and the cross-application
of different Sciences to each other was
the invention of new Sciences as I
already noted this was already the case
with the discipline of algebra which was
conceived as a new science with this
distinct subject matter technical
terminology method and title
in addition to its novelty the
significance of resumes algebra
is in the research triggered when
applied to other branches of mathematics
starting with me and until high end
famous
several mathematicians were fully aware
of the utility of the cross
fertilization of mathematical
disciplines and the novelty of this sort
of research so they did this is an
exercise which they engaged in
deliberately unconsciously it's not
you know by accident they deliberately
applied one discipline on to another
discipline to see what what the outcome
would be they concocted
they concocted unfamiliar titles for
their books coin technical terminology
unique to their disciplines organized
their works and decided the different
ways invented original mathematical
algorithms to solve the problems of
their disciplines above all they
conceived of totally new subjects and
mathematical Concepts such Innovations
were made possible by the deliberate and
systematic application in the case of
mathematics the application of algebra
arithmetic and geometry applying them to
each other
trigonometry is a is another hybrid
discipline the science of Weights is is
another discipline that was invented
conceptual and conceptualized as a new
science with its rules and principles
and so on pharmacology there are
numerous you know examples of point out
and pharmacology and and again the the
list goes on
another point that I would like another
sort of characteristic of the of the
practice of science is what I would call
the epistemological rehabilitation of
practical knowledge
the invention of numerous new scientific
disciplines did not result solely from
the trustful fertilization of different
theoretical Sciences but as much to the
attitude towards practical skills and
knowledge that derives from them
with the exception of some Die Hard
helliness the attitude in Muslim
societies do as practical crafts and
knowledge was fundamentally different
from the Greek one
in a culture that ascribes the highest
value to the legal religious Sciences
which are quintessentially practical
there was little room for a negative
attitude towards practical Sciences of
any sort
let right from the very beginning
utilitarian consideration provided
incentives for the pursuit of science as
mentioned earlier practical needs
included such subjects as land surveying
inheritance algebra irrigation
Technologies calendar computation and
timekeeping in addition to medicine and
related Sciences
the list of practice like practical
disciplines that were officially
recognized as Sciences is long and it
provides evidence for a different
attitude towards practical knowledge
these disciplines have distinct and
often completely new titles
moreover scientists did not shine away
from composing numerous books on these
subjects and they often explicitly
defended the epistemological value of
their knowledge and finally almost
invariably the classification of
Sciences genre which proliferated the
Muslim societies listed these practical
disciplines as full-fledged Sciences
let me give a couple of examples because
I think this is an important Point I've
already referred to the science of
mechanic mechanical devices
well I referred to it in my written
manuscript I I skipped it and and
the part that I read the science of
mechanical devices which of course Drew
on a rich Greek tradition what is
noteworthy in the Arabic tradition is
the Unapologetic promotion
of this graph to the level of science
and its subsequent development into what
for all practical purposes looks like
mechanical engineering
and I'll explain what I mean early
description of mechanical devices were
strictly schematic diagrams were used to
illustrate the theory underlying a
device and not to provide information on
its construction or relative dimensions
or or what have you the first book which
can be considered the mechanical
engineering handbook was
a book on knowing the
um
geometrical
means tricks but means mechanical tricks
by al-jazzari around 1200 in addition to
the schematic illustration of how
machines work the book gives detailed
instruction on the dimensions of the
various parts the materials to be used
and their treatment how they should be
treated for example lamination to
prevent trapping and so on I mean the
sort of stuff that I know from my
previous career
casting techniques and information on
finishing calibration and priming
procedures in short the book provides
all the information needed to
manufacture a machine not only to
understand the way it works
and this was considered science
I I have another example which I like
and I would like to share with you in in
the field of agronomy Agronomy and
agricultural Sciences
were cultivated with great success in
andalus in Spain
the numerous Works written in this field
underscore a conscious emphasis by
scientists on on the importance of
relying on practical knowledge and
deriving the principles the called mabad
of the science of agronomy those who
rely solely on pure philosophic on the
on the pure philosophical tradition are
pejoratively referred to as imitators
which is a term used in in the religious
Sciences as well usually in a negative
way because they do not grant their
assertion or knowledge derived from the
from practice from
in numerous instances where the flaws of
the philosophical agricultural tradition
are pointed out these sources insist
that the sound foundations of the
science of Agriculture
ought to combine theoretical
philosophical knowledge with knowledge
that derives from from manual work and
with experimentation which provides the
definitive proof burhan over which there
could be no doubt in One Source the
ideal specialist in the science of
Agriculture specialists in the sense of
Agriculture are called
which means the peasant philosophers or
the philosopher peasants I don't know
which way which is you know quite
interesting I think
again you know there are similar Trends
in the various mathematical disciplines
in medicine and so on and so forth these
and many other examples illustrate the
tendency to correlate theoretical and
practical knowledge and to treat the
crafts as Sciences thereby establishing
a stable Unity between theory and
practice one of the effects of this
promotion of practical knowledge was
also
a higher degree of professionalization
of science as a whole with the
increasing emphasis on its alliance with
practical disciplines but in my view one
of the most important outcomes of this
shift was the dramatic expansion of the
consumer base of scientific knowledge
put differently the tacit knowledge
needed to understand the Sciences was
now shared by significantly larger
sectors of the intellectual Elite of
Muslim Society
The Sciences were now dealing with
problems that punctured every aspect of
the daily lives of Muslims we have
already seen the example of the Qibla
how the discussion was conducted at
various levels
thereby allowing a much larger group of
people to take part in it another
realization of this trend is the
seemingly random use of old and as well
as new mathematical methods in the
solution of astronomical problems
hence the same author may use an archaic
method in one place and an advanced
method on another
for example theorem in one case and
design theorem in another which is more
advanced beruni for example uses both
the old cumbersome Menelaus theorem as
well as the new elegant sign Rule and
and several Solutions of the problem of
the direction of the Qibla this
simultaneous use of different
mathematical procedures can either be
attributed to the slow decimation of
dissemination of scientific knowledge
nor to The Limited circulation of this
knowledge there is ample evidence for a
high level of mobility and and of
efficient and Speedy communication among
scientists working in various regions of
the Muslim World by Rooney himself did
did not travel to Baghdad but he
apparently corresponded with and was
fully aware of scientific developments
there and elsewhere contrary to what it
may first suggest the use of different
methods is likely a result of the
increasing diffusion of scientific
knowledge among large segments of edge
of the educated Elite within the broad
ranks of these Elites
full-time scientists are expected to
keep up with the latest research in
their fields while Scholars with partial
interest in science would be familiar
only with the older theories and methods
the use of a variety of mathematical
methods is thus an indication of a
degree tool of the degree to which
scientific culture had filtered into
society and the extent to which it
became available to the average member
of the educated class
to the last point of today's lecture
everything we discussed today
demonstrates that the culture of science
struck deep roots in classical Muslim
societies various developments
contributed to the transformation of
science from peripheral peripheral
elitist activity as it has been in
earlier cultures to an institutionalized
activity with an unprecedented scale of
social support and and participation and
no earlier culture supported science to
the extent that it was supported of
course it's not similar to what it's but
it's different from what happened with
the rise of the new science of the
Scientific Revolution but prior to the
rise of Islam no other culture supported
science to the same extent and at the
same scale one aspect of the centrality
of scientific culture is the existence
of actual communities of scientists
which as we have seen had the sense of
collective professional identity
but more important than this Collective
sense of identity is that in their
respective fields of specialization
these communities share codes of
practice
canons of study and research agendas and
projects both empirical and theoretical
there is an underscore underscore at
this point is because so much earlier
work on the history of Islamic science
asserts that most of the original
discoveries and contributions of Islamic
science were isolated occurrences or as
the terms sometimes used happy guesses
that had no impact on their Islamic
environment and were only appreciated in
Latin Europe I could give you example
later on if you if you wish in the last
few decades the foundation foundational
research of all historians of Islamic
science has done much to under to
undermine this thesis but it continually
continues to inform the discussions of
General historians of science such as
for example Toby Huff Edward Grant and
the little reference that he makes in
his otherwise brilliant work but in the
later reference that he makes to Islam
he makes this point if you look the
chapter on Islam and Lindbergh's and
very in you know in many of the David
Lindbergh's works this is the point is
made over and over and over again
despite the work of historians of
Islamic science
research research has provided
compelling evidence for the continuity
and coherence of the Arabic scientific
tradition we've already referred to the
collaborative observational activities
starting in the 9th century and
continuing
unannabated for many centuries to come
other examples can be found in the
tradition of reforming ptolemaic
astronomy that started in the 11th
century and continued until at least the
16th and which spent most of the Islamic
work a definite and continuous research
research agenda which I will talk about
in Greater length the next time
guided the research of all the major
theoretical astronomers who read and
commented on each other and in some
cases even assembled together to conduct
joint research similarly research on the
disciplines of Arabic mathematics has
revealed that for each instance of
seemingly isolated scientific
breakthrough there are in fact
precedents and successors as well as a
community of Interest Scholars and
intellectuals more than any other
scholar Rusty Rashid has systematically
explored the the various mathematical
scientists sciences and established the
continuities in each and every one of
these disciplines in one example Russia
illustrates
Monumental contribution to the theory of
algebraic equations were not isolated as
general service of history of
mathematics often assert Russia chores
shows how hayam's work built on the
earlier tradition of algebraic
Christians and in any continuous
tradition and not just one or two
presidents but a continuous tradition
and constitutes only the beginning of a
long and continuous tradition that was
further transformed
a half century later by Shariff
in its analytical approach the work of
Tucson equations marks yet another
beginning of the discipline of algebraic
geometry the study of curse by means of
equations the point that I'm trying to
make is there are continuities but also
this continuities lead to New Beginnings
as it were
communities of Scholars that include not
only first-class mathematicians but also
commentators of lesser reputation as
well as Scholars working in other fields
contributed to the creation and
diffusion of a multitude of mathematical
traditions for every celebrated
scientist known to have conducted
rigorous research in any field of
science there are many more
practitioners Who provided the context
without which such such Advantage
advances would have been impossible
moreover we have records of simultaneous
discoveries or inventions of
mathematical theorems by more than one
scholar for example by Rooney in the
11th century by Rooney tells us that the
general theorem of science known as
known as the rule of four quantities was
discovered simultaneously and
independently by three astronomers from
huarism
from Baghdad Andrei
it is
aside from the claim of Precedence which
reflects an active competitiveness among
scientists which is itself interesting
in its own right
this account also suggests that a
discovery becomes inevitable on account
of the of the research needs of a
particular science and the accumulated
knowledge available to fulfill these
needs
in all the Sciences there always existed
communities of scientists that provided
temporal and spatial continuity for the
culture of science communities that
practiced what Thomas Kuhn would call
normal science
these normalized practices provided the
social as was as well as intellectual
contacts for the exceptional moments of
creativity in the history of Islamic
science
tested your patience so I better
conclude
I'm doing well right
in today's lecture I focused on the
context of the emergence and to some
extent the development of an arable
Islamic scientific culture
I also try to identify some common
patterns that characterize the practice
of science and remotes of scientific
thinking
I do recognize however that historical
continuity is not necessarily the same
as epistemological continuity and that
there is no necessary connection between
the historical formation of a science
and its theoretical and epistemological
structure
so important as contexts are I think
we need I at least do recognize that
contexts are touched together
and can only be so
moreover
contacts are multiple and at times
conflicting
so in the following two lectures
although I will not dispense with
context I will not be confined to it and
will rather try to focus on the
complexities of texts their internal
logic and their relation to various
intellectual traditions
in doing so I hope to describe and to
some extent perhaps even explain the
changes in the World Views connected and
resulting from these historical
practices of science
on the negative side of things
I will neither give an account of
Islamic science as the precursor of
European science law and many aspects it
was
nor as the scientific culture that
failed to produce the Scientific
Revolution a theme which seems to be a
staple of many brilliant accounts of the
rise of the new Sciences
brilliant there is in every regard
except when it comes to Islamic science
um
suffice it to say that the rise of the
new European science is a thing to be
explained and cannot be a principle of
explanation of something that happened
before it
in fact a better understanding of the
Islamic Sciences might contribute to
such explanations
but that is beyond the scope of my
lectures thank you
to use the microphone
I appreciate your
numerous examples of how Muslim Scholars
were prepared to
to engage and incorporate what we call
Natural Science into their work I
wondered if you could
give me a schematic as to how
what you were calling I think the
rational sciences and the religious
Sciences were related in that I wonder
if
um theology was elevated to the status
of a science like the sciences that
existed or whether
um science was incorporated and became a
form of theology yes or whether the two
were simply kept distinctly different
because unfamiliar with this dialogue uh
within Christianity and I see these
three Dynamics
as possibilities well there are several
questions in your question and the
reason I didn't address any of that
extremely important the reason I didn't
address them is that this these are the
topics of the next the next two lectures
one is on philosophy and Science and
specifically natural philosophy or
natural knowledge or natural science or
and that talk about these things next
time and the other is about religion's
life so
you know I
travel I don't wanna
you know I'm likely to come back
thank you for your lecture and for your
work I have a specific question and then
maybe a larger question which you may
also get to in a later lecture
um you said that no other culture had
paid as much attention to science in
certain specific ways maybe
institutionalization and so on and um
on that scale
um and I wonder if you would just
comment on Joseph Needham's work of
Chinese civilization and Science and so
on in relation to Islamic science
because he certainly makes a case uh in
in certain ways for the presence of
Science and Chinese culture so that's a
specific question and the the other one
is many years ago in a seminar at NYU
that I was at Franz Rosenthal a
professor from Yale came to this seminar
and said
um
the closing of the doors so to speak
um in Islam uh someone asked him what he
thought as to why that happened later in
Islamic history and his answer was quite
intriguing and he said
um almost like the present day he said
because they drowned in the amount of
knowledge that they had and they were
not able necessarily to find Clarity
forward it's almost like the information
of our own particular age anyway it was
a very insightful comment by a wonderful
historian of of Islam and so that's the
larger question if you want to just Muse
on that one too let me start with the
second one we all owe a lot to Professor
rosenthat's work
I think in particular what you know what
he might be referring to is the
proliferation of many new disciplines
I'm not sure but that's probably one of
the things that he had in mind the
proliferation of many new disciplines
you see the genre of classification
classifying The Sciences
was a very common job there are many
many many classifications and there are
some Scholars who looked at this John
and they said and they were confused
uh they didn't know what to make of it
because each each
scholar had their own classification and
what scenes at times as their own
different you know their own principles
of organizing knowledge and so on and so
forth
and some Scholars have were confused and
looking at this tradition uh they you
know as one particular scholar said you
know Muslims received this very neat
Greek classification system and they
started tagging on their own disciplines
to it and it became all confused and
useless and so on and so forth and so on
so of course Professor Rosenthal didn't
say that but I think and I will be
talking about that in in the next
lecture I think there is a there is a
problematic
uh which is beneath all these
classifications there are issues which
are B which people are thinking of I
mean they're thinking of about the
relationship between various traditions
and this is this is a shared sort of
problematic and one could trace Trends
in this and and the development of of
the field of the classification of
Sciences of course it keeps on changing
because there are new Sciences which are
being added so you have to fit them in
and you have to rethink the relationship
between them uh you have to rethink the
relationship between the specific
disciplines but also the relationship
between systems of knowing and this is
specifically what I'll be talking about
next time and there isn't one school
there are several schools
um but you know the the this is this is
part of the problematic that I'll be
addressing next time so hopefully I will
address that point to some extent next
time
as to you know competing with China
yeah maybe China
I'm happy you know either way
but the scale is is quite large
certainly
at least in comparison to the to the
Traditions that that informed the
Islamic Sciences the scale is much
larger
I appreciated your presentation very
much
in regard to the translation or the
transmission of Aristotle to the West
was there a what should we say common
interest or a common concern for
monotheism which was present in
Aristotle and also in Islam which made
it possible for the Muslims to adopt
Aristotle as a philosopher of Their Own
elected
well
Aristotle was
the first
sort of
full-fledged philosopher in the Islamic
tradition was a person by the name of
candy
and right from the beginning
Candy's reading of I mean it wasn't a
perfect reading of Aristotle he is not
the one who commanded Aristotle most
modern you know I mean it's a it's a
it's a gradual process but already in
the work of ofil kendi
you find that philosophy is if not
subjugated to religion is harmonized
with religion so candy has you know in
the agenda of elkindi and therefore in
his reading of Aristotle he wants to use
aristotleons and to to the extent that
it's possible of course it's not always
possible to do that as a way to in some
cases to reinforce religious beliefs and
and traditions of course this Falls
outside my my
area of interest but we see in the
earliest sort of works and and you know
on I feel philosophical philosophical I
said the Islamic philosophical tradition
which is of course primarily
Aristotelian we see attempts to to bring
in religious concerns and to to deal
with them of course when we move forward
to someone like farabi farabi is is
truer to the Aristotelian tradition and
less willing to compromise the tradition
and the interest of religion but then
again we have an Encina who's probably
more systematic and Aristotelian than
Aristotle himself if I may say so again
but
deals with questions which Aristotle
didn't deal with I mean he discusses
issues of existence and and issues which
intersect with with the religion
and you know he's he's the he has a
whole theory about
necessary existence and so on and so
forth which had its religious utility if
you will
uh now
whether Aristotle lens himself
to
a monotheistic interpretation
I'm not an expert on Aristotle and some
people would argue yes that he does
he certainly was used
you know he was sort of interpreted
in Christian theology
in ways you know which made him useful
for for the Christian theological
arguments and there are similar there
are some similar patterns in the Islamic
tradition and multiple and very diverse
I'm sorry if my answer is not clear it's
because it's not exactly my subject
first of all thank you for your
presentation I have one question
um
unfortunately
doing like some of the uh classical
reformers otters in 19th century claimed
like Ottoman Empire for the decline in
science in Islam like Islamic world and
I know for a fact that there had been
some clash as between religion and Islam
there have been some clash between
religion
Islam and Science and Ottoman Empire
because uh for certain research for
example the permission has to be taken
from the caliph and the fatwa and it
wasn't given was it was this Clash uh
just specific to Ottoman Empire or did
it happen in other dynasties prior to
Ottoman Empire was there a clash between
religion Islam and science
I don't know the exact example that
you're referring to the clash in the
ottoman
but
irrespective of what that example may be
I mean you know Islamic history is more
than 14 centuries now so there are
instances of course of clashes and but
there are instances of Harmony
which doesn't mean that you know we
leave it at that I will be arguing in
the next lectures that there are main
sort of Trends and I will try to you
know try to explain these Trends and and
so on and so forth you can always find
instances of this or that anywhere but
again you know there are larger Trends
which are reflected in writings and
practices and so on and so forth
of course there were instances some
instances of clash and you know one of
the which I heard in my written
manuscript but I had to skip one of the
most information Works in in on on the
history of
relationship between science and
religion was composed by a gold year
more than a century ago
it's called the attitude of Orthodox
Islam towards the ancient Sciences
uh the the old
there is something which is throtta
today I forgot anyway something is hello
and here we go there Marshalls all the
evidence for conflict and contradiction
uh again Professor Gutta says section in
his book that is the book that that I
mentioned where he sort of takes on
golsir's argument very systematically
um I mean it's still conscious argument
still informs someone like probably half
who knows nothing about the history of
Science in any tradition you know Toby
have wrote this book about why the
science the Scientific Revolution
happened in in Europe and not in China
or in Islam
and I think he doesn't know anything
about any of these three Traditions but
he his main source is called here you
know
everything he knows about Islamic
Sciences practically from this one
article by culture it remains a very
influential article
and there are people who assert that
there is a conflict and contradiction or
whatever I will be speaking to that in
the next two lectures uh you know I will
not sort of fixate on it I think it's
it's you know historians have dealt with
this issue but if someone has specific
questions but this is something that
I'll be addressing next time but more so
in the third lecture which is
exclusively on the relationship between
nature
science feels like it's bad yeah the
words for Science and Arabic is which
means knowledge
and usually use the word Diamond
construct or something else you say the
island the science of the knowledge of
literally but
or the science of whatever it is so
religious science is a system of
knowledge which deals with religious
subjects as opposed to rational Sciences
which was used the term was used I mean
these are these are terms which are
amusing terms which were actually used
by you know in in the current practices
in The Classical period And even today
the rational Alum lately the rational
Sciences or uh you could be more
specific you'll say the science of of
nature or which we now call physics or
you could say whatever you know the
science of Weights the science of uh
Hadith traditions of the Prophet the
science of law of applied law and so on
and so forth so these are the you know
the the term itself is knowledge and it
applies everywhere but the distinction
was quite clear well it's not quite
clear actually the distinction and again
this is something that I will talk about
I mean the way the distinction was
negotiated it didn't really you know
it's not clear-cut always and there are
changes that happen over time but by and
large there are General sort of
practices which are distinguished from
each other and these are categorized I
mean these General practices are on the
one hand the traditional religious
disciplines if you win which were called
they're religious sciences and the
rational Sciences
I don't know if I answered the question
but I'll be saying much more about this
next time
thanks very much Professor for a very
enlightening lecture my question
actually starts with a remark from
France Rosenthal that we just heard
which I find very interesting and it
reminds me of an article that the young
penis published in 1938 about the
relationship in this case between uh and
the survival in this case of of
philosophy and science is after the 12th
century to by and large regarded dead
before that time there in the article of
1938 he makes the point that uh in Islam
The Sciences
are characterized largely by a synthetic
attitude in this case bringing together
different Traditions from the Greeks
from from the Hellenistic world of
course from India from Babylonia and all
that and he somewhat uh
um he somewhat contrasts that with
scientific attitude in in Europe and I
don't know whether we would like to con
to comment on that in this case just
want to you know more or less uh invite
you to contrast that to Europe yeah in
Northway well that's of course something
that he doesn't go into that in in the
in that article very very closely but
what he just says is what characterizes
Islamic science is in the pursuit of
Islamic Sciences is particular this idea
of basically bringing together and and
consciously apparently consciously
wanting to bring together uh different
traditions
and yeah and I just want to invite you
as I as I said in my argument I think
the the multiplicity of traditions was
quite instrumental not so much in in in
that they had equal weight they didn't I
mean the Greek tradition was by far much
more influential than any other
tradition and for understandable reasons
it was much more systematic it was more
you know and so on and so forth it was
you know a coherent system
which is you know which appealed to the
and had much more influence in the but I
think my my argument is that the
multiplicity of traditions uh enabled a
posture towards you know towards the the
sciences that were being imported which
is a critical posture right from the
beginning there was an awareness that
you have choices
and again we see it we see it in
astronomy we see it in mathematics we
see it in medicine we see it in all the
traditions and from the earliest period
so there is an awareness that there are
multiple traditions and with this
awareness you don't take a tradition you
know in all completely and just accept
it as is you're willing to think it over
you're willing to question it to some
extent this is number one and secondly I
agree with you and I agree with if you
know with what you attributed to to the
article that there was a in in many
instances there was a deliberate
application of one discipline to another
discipline leading
to the creation of a third discipline in
the mathematical disciplines this is
very very clear I mean you know the
application of arithmetics and geometry
and and
algebra
they are applying them to each other in
every instance invariably led to the
creation of a new field
but there is more I mean the application
of algebra to to to Statics
and the creation of the signs of weights
and and so on and so forth I mean it's
not just in in one discipline
um so the the the intentional
cross-application is also so the
hybridity is I think important for this
critical sort of approach to the to the
imported legacies and the
cross-application is critical for is
important for the invention of new
scientific traditions and both were
quite quite significant you know in the
practice of science
thank you very much
we have all of you and
uh
foreign